à l'usiné edf de bellefontaine un
showroom explique aux visiteurs comment
nous réduisant notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles
récemment avec la centrale de
grèce donc à dans rivière des éoliennes
avec du stockage la centrale aussi d'al
biomasse qui ont été mises en service
récemment on est à peu près à 25%
d'énergies renouvelables dans tout le
mix énergétique de marty chaque états de
la caraïbe de l'est se bat pour
augmenter sa production d'énergie
renouvelable
l'enjeu est d'abord climatique tendent
aux îles sont menacées par la montée des
eaux
mais il est tout aussi économiques pour
nous le coût de l'électricité est très
cher il affecte notre compétitivité
alors si nous pouvons produire nous
mêmes notre énergie locale qu'elle soit
soleil hydro géothermique ou éolienne
elle va nous aider à réduire nos coûts
de production réduire notre dépendance
la pollution passe d'abord par la
maîtrise de notre consommation globale
d'énergie
en martinique des économies
considérables sont actuellement réalisés
ont co financent le passage de
l'éclairage performant à du chauffe eau
solaire à de l'isolation de toiture plus
des grosses opérations en faveur des
industriels et l'ensemble de ces
opérations conduit à des économies de
l'ordre de 30 gigawatts heure par an
qu'on retrouve sur la baisse de la
consommation donc et cet effort va
continuer à accroître la part des
énergies renouvelables en martinique a
bondi de 7% en 2010 est à 25 aujourd'hui
l'objectif fixé pour 2020 3 et 2 58%